A sensible estimate would be E times the ratio of the first to the difference.
Let's look at why that is the case.
We know that for the forward Euler's method, the global truncation error that this kind of error
depends on the step size in almost the linear fashion.
This error that I am looking for here is the GTE for h1.
We see that E, the error between the two numerical solutions, appears here.
So now there's two similar triangles. The first one is here and the second one is here.
Let's look at the following ratio error/h1. This has to equal E/h2-h1,
and hence, the error is equal to E*h1 times up divided by the difference.
I'm writing an equal sign here but of course that's just a rough estimate.
This dependance is not strictly linear and we're assuming
that these three points are almost on a line.
This may not be perfect in practice.